good cry good go and wanna cry yes you
should cry stop stop being embarrassed
and just cry because you have passion
and you care and it's an inspiration you
don't think you don't think people who
watch this will be inspired and say hey
I can kind of relate to that what's up
party people
happy Monday doing another day in the
life today is a Monday for me Monday is
mentoring day I meet with Lily in the
morning help her with her business then
I go and Instagram live and answer your
questions then I got Alex in the
afternoon helping him build TDS it's all
about training the people who are
closest in my life helping those
entrepreneurs go and you guys get to tag
along for the ride you get it oh you
gonna give you a high five there you go
okay it's not about you Alex about Lily
okay so lily and I are meeting how long
have I known you why you laughing
Lily started as a instructor here at TDS
a while ago and in when we're meeting I
told her that we're gonna start a
business together
and then about a year later we came up
with an idea and we made it happen
Lily started off saying she wants to be
a speaker she saw herself on stage and I
said I can help with that let's turn
that into a business and that was a
start and then that evolved from
speaking to coaching the workshops to
whole bunch of fun stuff once a week we
meet up there talking about Lily's
business so I've invested into Lily's
company and part of that is helping her
grow mentorship connections advice
opportunities ideas so every Monday we
meet up for a couple hours sometimes
we'll do a review of a recent coaching
called
but otherwise it's just checking in see
how she's doing see how we can grow and
today we've been focused on my workshop
so I have a three-day workshop here in
Toronto helping thought-leaders make
money from their ideas
Lily's leading a couple of the sessions
so we got a brainstorm how it's going to
work what we're going to talk about make
sure we're on the same page so that we
give an awesome experience to the people
who come out one of the main focuses
that Lily was getting back to basics we
had a bunch of ideas that she's been
working on and her schedule kind of got
exploded and blew out and had to focus
back on the core of what we're doing we
just coaching she can do up to 16
sessions a week and she's hitting about
twelve right now because she got
distracted doing other stuff all
important projects but got to get back
to basics got to be hitting 14 15 16 out
of 16 to put the reps in get better and
continue to work on upon success
improving their skills and coach so if
you bring more value okay alright I have
to wake up both these dogs they're both
they're both relaxing on me right now
okay guys it's Lily's fault remember
that okay right you excited Teemo are we
done we are going live again happy
Monday I missed you I was away all last
week at two events Philadelphia and then
Palm Springs and I'm happy to be back we
have a new addition to the family meet
just Anna she just woke up so she's dead
but I'm back on the horse back on the
tradition 12:30 Eastern going on
Instagram and
questions giving some love - super
saying where we got Abhishek one two one
five five welcome the lines 18 walking
14 they're lovely
we've got he's got the vlog good with me
today they're trying to stay out of the
shot but I'm trying to get him in the
shot there they are deep evolve in the
house I want to know I want to know
first up who your hero is I posted this
morning about heroes and I think I think
people play smile by default I think we
just we play small by default we wake up
every day and do the things that our
environment tells us to do and our
heroes allow us to break free of that
when you have somebody who you look up
to who gives you the air cover to be
able to then go off and do the thing you
want to do think it's important I
surround myself with people like Elon
Musk and Steve Jobs and all the videos
that I make because it gives me
motivation to do more to push harder
because a lot of people in my life are
unfortunate that everybody's telling me
how great a job I'm doing I want people
to push you to do more to go harder and
so when I watch I still have a long way
to go
and so I think when you surround
yourself with new euros as much as
possible it pushes you to play a bigger
game if you guys have questions I want
to join in live but we've got happy to
serve on
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright guys another awesome chat
linking the love where I mean it over
which means I am late for this guy right
okay anyway thank you guys to the love
it's great to be back tomorrow we're
gonna do the same time Cole three all of
you guys want to join me live now you
get there at 12:30 Eastern be the first
put your hand up and say pick me and
let's have a conversation because I want
to help thank you to the love panel
today to do something important make
living matter there's a lot of time left
to be able to do something that you're
going to want to show your grandkids so
let's see it lets see it lets see it
it's great when I can get one or two
decent conversations the topic of today
seem to be about judgment people wanting
to do something but their parents want
them to do something else with their
friends went into something else for the
cousins want them to do something else
and really just at some point you need
to decide that it's gonna be your life
and not somebody else's version of your
life and people are looking for
permission to go off and do it and it's
great I give them the permission to do
it I give it a little bit of a
motivational boost to go out and do the
thing they want to do but it frustrates
me because I don't want them they don't
they don't need me they really have the
thing they need to go out from the other
thing and so many people are so talented
but they have a mindset that they allow
other people in there and your cousins
and your parents and your friends they
don't they don't want what you want so
you got to figure out what you want have
your purpose and protect it because
otherwise you're never going to do the
thing that you're meant to do
[Music]
I have a bit of a concern that I don't
know how to deal with it but watching a
video today it has to do with the
stories I'm losing a bit of passion for
it the stories and I'm wondering if it's
just a matter of adjustment so but well
hide away just story the story is great
like
like I can't just drop it
if you're not into it if your hearts
that into it then you have to switch but
what's the difference between someone
just being impulsive and just keep
switching and never never be satisfied
like that's not a good that's not a good
lifestyle either right it's impossibly
switching from one thing to another
like I get the passion but where how do
you draw where do you draw the line how
do you like how do you measure that if
someone's being impulsive simply versus
like authentically not being passionate
about something if you're being
impulsive then you need to you need to
plan for impulsivity into your life into
your business but the mission that
you're on is constant like you haven't
switched from belong belong is what
you're trying to do that doesn't change
but how you going to accomplish it might
change if you're an impulsive person and
then you try to be straight-laced and do
the same thing every day you're gonna
you're gonna you're gonna die you can be
disciplined for so long and then you're
gonna hate your life so while you still
have one foot in the door you make the
best of it and then you find the next
thing people need belong every day so
whether the whole semesters about it I
think it's just having the ability to be
flexible and switch things up when it's
not serving you anymore but ultimately
you still want you just wait to attach
to the house the house doesn't matter
sure it does ah not when it doesn't work
when the house doesn't get you there
nothing is gonna ever fully work better
don't keep switching it yeah maybe it's
in the variety that it works
perfect person no you're not even that
you're not even into that variety that
much like I'm doing Joe I'm joking
oh no I'm not but look at how much
variety that you want to now add from
the person who loves structure and
stability now imagine coaching people
who like variety more than you and how
fresher they're going to be with the
system you don't want to train a bunch
of people to work at McDonald's
I don't know man I don't know what the
answer is I don't know I don't know what
I should be doing now that's a good
problem to have
frustration will lead to results no I'm
serious
because of the pain discomfort now you
get you'll get something but doing the
same thing I entered this doing the same
thing won't like won't get you where you
want to go you're gonna just get more
frustrated with it and the others are
feeling it legit like what am I supposed
to do you don't know you're gonna figure
it out I'm teaching today tomorrow
Wednesday Thursdays you figured out
you're figuring it out you don't know
yet strained easy to do this great
that's some awesome vulnerability there
yep I don't if I didn't want to keep
going my youtube channel where I was
frustrated I'd make a video saying guys
I don't know what I'm gonna do with my
YouTube channel I'm really frustrated
why even do the hose or just do you
wanna do the Huddle's do you like the
Huddle's is it the Huddle's is the
message the Huddle's are the speech or
the question it's it's it's it's
this is an example of evolved by the way
because you're taking something that
you've been doing and have all this
commitment to write all this sunk cost
in and now you're willing to let it go
to go do the unknown you don't have a
plan yet you're gonna make the plane
that's that's inspirational I don't know
if you can see my body language right
now but I'm slowly like shriveling up
inside
no you're exploding of Awesomeness
inside good you should cry why don't you
go for it right right cuz I feel so lost
listen chemotherapy died he's a therapy
dog they're coming I feel so lost right
now as I tried to build the best good
cry good go and one across yes you
should cry stop stop being embarrassed
and just cry
because you have passion and you care
and it's an inspiration you don't think
you don't think people who watch this
will be inspired and say hey I can kind
of relate to that no because we have to
be perfect all the time
because you can't make mistakes guys I
gotta get my thyroid checked or
something right it's sure you get
permission to everybody else who's ever
felt like they made a mistake or they've
been fighting and it hasn't worked out
now you're gonna make it into the vlog
okay now you now you desert now you're
in your way in
[Laughter]
that's permission you're given
permission to others who are judging
their feelings for the exact same thing
right blaming their thyroids and all
this other stuff I can't cry in front of
somebody else you're giving permission
for others to do it just like admitting
that you're moving on in a different
direction you're give them permission
everybody else to do it that's the win
that's the lesson is evolved right there
you've already done it
[Music]
it's just been
it's so exhausting to fight for
something when so many people feel
comfortable with it
and when you have so few wins you get
bored of it or it's just not working and
you have to drop it and I know it's
ongoing and I shouldn't put my self
worth and the thing that I do like the
execution of it yeah that's it
it's just the execution of it it's
always been fighting for the right thing
and you're still fighting for the same
thing you're just too attached to the
how you got there it's just like how do
I I don't see this finish line and I
know that there is no finish line yeah
the best instructor right I'm having the
best school right and doing all these
amazing things but I thought I was
getting close to something where I was
like okay I just need to get good enough
in it but you are getting close this is
actually getting you closer how do you
teach this all this pain and all the
struggle and guide people through this
that's welcome to everybody's life is
pain and struggle it's not teaching how
to get there it's teaching how to pull
through and recognize that it's okay
your pain and struggle and and exposing
and opening your heart makes it easier
for other people to do it it's an
inspiration the awareness is a huge step
forward you think you're lost but you're
way closer to the truth than you realize
this isn't ten steps back it's a giant
leap forward I know but you have to out
of frustration and despair and
uncertainty comes awesomeness stick into
doing what you're doing that's causing
pain and suffering for ten more years is
not the solution to getting a happy life
I don't know why you're smiling this
great this is a great day this is a
great day this is an amazing day it's
just this is great you need that you
need to you need to see it is great like
if you want to help other people this
part everybody's gonna go through this
you you want to try to guide any future
person through it I've been through it
so when they start getting down they
gotta know how to I don't know I don't
know what to do I feel like everything
all I can do is be you all I can do is
follow your structure but I know it's
not fitting for me I feel lost that's
that's the turning point to make
something great
as you can see alex is struggling with
the the self-doubt with putting so much
work into something that not paying off
and finally thinking you have something
and then realizing it's not the thing
and it's a human problem I think all of
us go through that and he's not quite
understanding it yet but he will with a
little bit of time he's still processing
it and he's he takes things very
emotionally which is his strength but
once he processes it he'll he'll do
really really really well I think
ultimately that's how he wins
it's his humanist I think people can
connect to him because he gets emotional
about things and really at the end of
day he cares so much like you will not
meet and oh they can being who cares
more about other people in the work that
he's doing than Alex and so it's because
he cares so much that he gets you know
so emotionally involved but I think the
message ultimately is you need to evolve
the work that you do either on a big
scale and a little scale constantly I
think a lot of people start off on one
path and they love it and then they
realize they want to do something else
that wasn't for them but they stick in
it and that's how you end up in the same
job for 30 years and hate in your life
because you never made the adjustment
and so the trick is to try to catch
these adjustments sooner to not let it
get to the point where you absolutely
hate your life and it must change
because everything is just so dreadful
to try to find these little micro
moments where you're shifting you want
something else but you're not doing the
thing anymore
even though it's even though it's led
you to success it's not what's going to
take you to the next spot and I think
too often people allowed the success of
the past to be anchors that prevent them
from moving towards the next center if
you hate everything it's easy to want to
make a shift but it's when it's good
when it was great and now which is good
it's hard to leave that to go off for
the unknown like what am I gonna do next
I don't know and so why I love the
moment was because I think everybody can
relate to that he's suffering in it he's
sooo struggling right now but he'll get
through it and I think that's a that's
an inspiration for the people and so
what I'd love to impart is if you're
feeling frustrated or down or negative
or uncertain
that's an amazing place to be because
out of that will come the next bit of
explosive creativity for yourself so we
just went over this long intensive
conversation right now I feel really
good and I think mostly because I was
able to again evolve and let go of
putting my self-worth in a practice that
I do in class like me being an amazing
instructor I keep trying to remember
that is it's not how I execute it's my
passion behind it it's my my love in my
care
so as much as I was overwhelmed I'm
starting to move on it's kind of funny
because three four weeks ago I asked my
students I said how do you know when you
should put on something and me
struggling and probably crying in front
of the camera which you'll see we saw
earlier it's the same answer I wasn't
passionate about the process and as I
started to get less passionate about how
I was doing it the students could see
people were uncomfortable with it and
it's just you know when you quit when
your heart tells you that you're not in
it and so I've come to terms with my
heart is not in it I feel better now and
I'm more excited about going to the next
thing trying to figure out right now how
to make it work better and so I'm
excited about today's class actually
so another great day in the books hope
you guys found some value in it one of
the themes that I think kept coming up
over and over and over again was just
that while you were on your journey to
create something amazing for yourself
there's gonna be a lot of roadblocks and
me a lot of bumps you're gonna make
mistakes there's gonna be a lot of
uncertainty and to embrace that instead
of just seeing the failures as this
impossible thing that you're never going
to overcome and you're never gonna win
that failures are part of the process
that uncertainty is a part of the
process that that the less you know the
more exciting that actually is because
it gives you the chance to go off and
create something new that out of the
frustration in pain and in crappiness of
the feeling that you're getting right
now that will allow you to build
something amazing whether that's you
know the Dane school or video business
or something else if you're in a if
you're in a hole right now I just
encourage you to try to think of the
positive that from this the Phoenix will
rise you will come out of the ashes and
build something amazing
this is the Maya it's weird cuz I was
walking today and I was think about
decided because he never gets open any
package oh my god you can't imagine how
much it he gets way too many packages
they keep asking can I open the packages
because the funnest part of we're
getting anything is opening the package
and he says no so I finally get the
cameras here wow this is don't bend I
heard it already and I heard you say
okay I'm good oh oh it's me oh that's
pretty awesome like it's part of your
book I think No okay listen people can't
see so this is the this is an Instagram
guy I think he wanted me to sign this oh
cool okay that's him
yeah yeah I think it's one of the quotes
in my book there you got to open up a
package did you feel great yeah
if anybody wants to do a caricature of
Alex Jack Matt on McKean from Ireland
Wow all right yeah the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple so it would be like
a little beacon hey believe nation if
you want to know what the most important
one word is for Tony Robbins Gary
Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am and
Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details